Bitte schön.
Okay. Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ust-Ul-Lar. Ich bin als Aufzuseh-Station. Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahme-Geschrefen. Ist das okay für Sie?
Ja.
Ersterde ich irre personische Datum-Aufnahme und dann komme ich gleich zu Iran aktuellen Bechwertung. Okay?
Zagınse Mia Bitte Irename, Vorname? Erst?
Mein Name ist Peter Leffas. Vorname Peter. Ja.
Name Leffas. Leffas.
Könnt ihr bitte Irename büstebieren? Ja. L, I, F, F, I, R, S. Leffas. Leffas. Okay.
Herr Leffas, wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 58 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie genau geboren? Am 15. April 1964.
64, ja. Okay. Und wissen Sie, wie groß sind Sie? Ja, 1,84 m.
84, okay. Und wie viel wiegen Sie da? 82 kg.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen? Was für Bechwärte haben Sie denn? Ja, mir geht es seit 2 Tagen nicht so gut.
Ich bin müde und habe Lieder- und Lenkschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen, Pusten. Und ich habe auch heute Fieber gemessen.
Und das war ziemlich hoch für mich. 39,4. Okay. Haben Sie nur einmal gemessen oder?
Vorhin ja, vor einer Stunde. Und dann haben wir gesagt, jetzt muss ich ins Krankenhaus.
Okay. Sie haben gut gemacht, so um es kommen. Ja, seit 2 Tagen haben Sie Fieber oder nur heute?
Also, ich glaube schon, dass ich auch seit 2 Tagen Fieber habe. Aber heute ist es, glaube ich, noch angestiegen.
Okay. Sie haben höchstens, ja, gibt es dabei auswurfs? Ja, das sieht so ein bisschen rötlich aus.
Rötlich. Schleim, geldlich, rötlich, ja. Okay.
Haben Sie auch Wurstschmerzen beim Pusten? Ja, auch beim Einatmen tut es mir auf der linken Seite weh, wenn ich Luft holen will.
Und wenn ich Wüste, tut es auch weh. Okay. Okay. Haben Sie Luftnoten oder?
Einfach schon. Also, ich musste eben hier eine Treppe hochsteigen und das war schon nicht so gut.
Da habe ich auch etwas wenig Luft bekommen, ja. Okay. Okay.
Ja. Haben Sie geschwollene Beine bemerkt? Nein, das habe ich nicht. Hab ich noch nie gehabt.
Okay. Haben Sie eine Hautfarbe, eine Farbe, eine Bemerk, zum Beispiel, Bilalüche, Lipen oder? Nein.
Nein. Okay. Und haben Sie solche Bechwerte schon einmal erlebt oder das ist so erst mal?
So etwas habe ich noch nie erlebt. Ich habe auf häufigerweise eine Prontitis mehrmals im Jahr.
Da habe ich so eine Prontitis, aber nie groß mit Fieber oder Luftnot und Schmerzen.
Wann war das?
Zuletzt hatte ich eine Prontitis vor vier Monaten. Vor vier Monaten.
Aber nicht zu schlimm. Okay.
Ja. Rauchen Sie? Ja, ich rauche schon ziemlich lange, seit ungefähr 35 Jahren.
35 Jahren. Wie viel? Rauchen Sie Zigaretten oder? Zigaretten, 20 am Tag.
20. Okay. Okay. Haben Sie normale weiße chronische Hüsten?
Ja, ich habe schon häufiger Hüsten und einige Male im Jahr auch eine Prontitis.
Manchmal brauche ich dann von meinem Arzt auch Antibiotika.
Okay. Haben Sie Nachschweiß oder Schüttelfrost?
Jetzt seitdem ich das so habe, seit zwei Tagen, da schwitze ich sehr stark auch nachts
und hatte auch anfangs etwas Schüttelfrost, sonst habe ich das nicht.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Der ist nochmal gut, aber jetzt seit zwei Tagen ist mein Appetit nicht so gut, da habe ich nicht viel gegessen.
Haben Sie ein Lester, ein Gewichtferloren? Nein.
Okay. Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein, das Stuhlgang ist in Ordnung, Wasser lassen.
Auch, ich muss einmal nachts auf Toilette Wasser lassen, einmal.
Aber dann kann ich sofort einstaufen, dass alles gut ist.
Okay.
Okay. Und ja, wegen der aktuellen Beschwerde haben Sie auch Herzrasen oder Herzklopfen bemerkt?
Nein, ich glaube, mein Puls ist jetzt etwas schneller, aber meine Frau sagt, das kommt durch das Fieber.
Okay. Wie ist Ihr Schlaf? Sie haben gesagt, nur einmal gehen Sie auf Toilette, aber sonst ist es gut.
Sonst kann ich gut schlafen, ja.
Okay. Ja, haben Sie noch weitere Beschwerde?
Meinen Sie Krankheiten oder?
Nein, aktuell. Leiden Sie weitere Beschwerden?
Okay. Aber ich fühle mich einfach krank, ich fühle mich schlapp und müde und kakut.
Ich kann verstehen, ja. Hallo, falls. Ja.
Und, tinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke so eine Flasche Bier am Tag, also am Abend, eine Flasche Bier.
Ja.
Aber nicht mehr und keinen Schnaps, aber Bier.
Okay. Seit wann tinken Sie?
Das ist auch so ungefähr, seitdem ich brauche, seit 35 Jahren.
Okay.
Und bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht, pardon, das ist eine reine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie erfahrt mit dem Droge?
Nein, habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Okay. Ja.
Haben Sie Allergie?
Allergie.
Nein, ich vertrage alles, ich habe bisher, nein.
Nein, nein.
Ja, am voralltragenden Kunden haben sie Bronschitis und auch chronische Hüsten.
Hab ich?
Ich hauste relativ oft und häufiger habe ich auch eine Bronschitis,
aber das ist nicht immer, mehrmals Jahr habe ich das.
Anders im Winter, im Herbst, dann ist das so für mich häufig,
dass ich da mal eine Bronschitis über längere Zeit habe.
Ja, okay.
Und leiden Sie weiter an Vorarlkranken?
Ich habe erhöhte Blutfette und mein Cholesterin ist etwas zu hoch
und dafür nehme ich ein Medikament ein.
Was nehmen Sie?
Das heißt, ich muss hier nachschauen,
10 mg steht das.
10 mg.
Nehmen Sie noch weitere Medikamenten?
Nein.
Ich habe noch eine andere Medikament.
Wenn ich vielleicht eine schwere Bronschitis habe,
dann kann es mal sein, dass der Arzt mir für eine oder zwei Wochen
einen Antibiotikum aufschreibt.
Ja, okay.
Ja, haben Sie wegen der Bronschitis eine arztische Diagnose bekommen?
Ja, mein Arzt sagt, das wäre schon eine chronische Bronschitis,
sagt er wohl, und das Wichtigste wäre, ich sollte das Rauchen aufhören.
Ja, aber...
Haben Sie probiert, mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören?
Noch nicht so richtig.
Wenn Sie wollen, vielleicht können wir Ihnen helfen dabei.
Das wäre vielleicht jetzt ganz gut, ja, können wir probieren.
Okay.
Wollt ihr uns als Kind operieren?
Operiert wurde ich als Kind.
Da wurde ich operiert einmal, da war ich, glaube ich, acht Jahre am Blindern.
Und dann hatte ich noch einen Leistenbruch auf der linken Seite,
da war ich, glaube ich, zehn Jahre alt.
Vor zehn Jahren?
Nein, da war ich zehn Jahre alt.
Also als Kind?
Ja, alle Fersen.
War es in der Starzeit im Ausland?
Nein, bei Corona sind wir nicht großvereist,
nur wir waren etwas in Deutschland, in der See, aber nicht im Ausland.
Und sind Sie vollständig gegen Corona geimpft?
Ich bin dreimal geimpft, ja.
Dreimal.
Okay.
Haben Sie wegen dieser aktuellen Bescheid,
eine Corona-Schinaltest, Covid-Schinaltest machen lassen?
Eine Corona-Schinaltest? Nein, bis jetzt nicht.
Okay.
Nein. Okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Taxifahrer.
Taxifahrer.
Okay. Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Taxifahren ist schon viel Stress.
Man muss viel Stress.
Manchmal viel Stress mit den Fahrgästen, manchmal viel Verkehr,
in Stau stehen, Zeitdruck, das ist schon stressig.
Ja, ich kann das verstehen.
Sind Sie perheitert?
Ja.
Okay, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei Kinder habe ich.
Sind Sie gejagt oder?
Ja, das sind beide, die sind Töchter, die sind 30 Jahre und 27 Jahre,
die haben beide eine chronische Schildrösenentzündung.
Mit einer leichten Unterfunktion, da müssen Sie auch ein Medikament nehmen.
Okay.
Und machen Sie regelmäßig Sport oder haben Sie dafür seid?
Nein, der einzige Sport, den ich mache, ist ich schaue im Fernsehen Fußball.
Okay. Das ist gut auch.
Ja, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein, mein Vater ist mit 80 Jahren verstorben.
80 Jahre.
An Lungenkrebs?
Ja, es tut mir sehr leid.
Ja, die Mutter lebt noch, die ist 82 Jahre alt, die hat etwas hohen Blutdruck
und auch etwas Alterszucker, aber sonst geht es dir ganz gut.
Okay, Gott sei Dank.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe keine Geschwister mehr.
Ja, Herr Lefers, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen Ihnen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, mich interessiert natürlich, was das sein kann,
was Sie denken, wo Sie einen Verdacht haben.
Ja, vielleicht, ja, ich habe natürlich eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Sie leiden eventuell an einer Lungeninfektion oder vielleicht Corona,
aber wir müssen erst sicher gehen.
Deswegen brauchen wir einfach Untersuchungen Ihnen durchführen.
Bitte bleiben Sie bei uns und nach dem alle Ergebnisse würde ich gerne darüber
mit Ihnen widersprechen.
Ja, okay.
Ja, gut.
Prima.
Danke.
Dann brauchen Sie wieder fünf Minuten zum...
Nein, haben Kollegen Fragen.
Ich habe keine Frage.
Wir können anfangen.
Okay.
Wir können anfangen, Herr Helko.
Von mir aus gerne.
Oder brauchen Sie noch etwas Zeit?
Ich möchte das dann probieren.
Ja, gut, prima.
Danke.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen vorstellen, hätten Sie dafür sein?
Ja, natürlich.
Okay.
Es handelt sich um Peter Leffern.
Er ist 58 Jahre alt, 1,84 Meter groß und 2,80 Kilogramm schwer.
Er ist heute seit zwei Tagen 5-tähernd
Grippe- und Symptom-Siebte.
Er klagt über Fieber.
Er habe sein Fieber 30,5 Grad gemessen.
Er habe Fieber seit zwei Tagen.
Heute ist das Fieber angestickt.
Er hat auch Hüsten mit Sputum.
Sputum ist rötlich, schleimig und gerblich.
Er begleitet die Hüste von links- und zur links- und zur links-Siebte.
Er ist bei Einatmen und bei Inspiration.
Er hat auch Belastungdissignal.
Diese Symptome ist erst mal aufgetreten.
Er hat auch die Symptome aufgetreten.
Sie haben das sehr gut systematisch gemacht mit der Anamese.
Sie haben das sehr ruhig gemacht und klare Fragen gestellt.
Sie haben die Vorstellung zum Oberarzt übersetzt.